So Eleanor was just a kid, eight or nine, standing at a corner waiting to cross the street, minding her own business.
埃莉诺当时还是个孩子，八九岁，站在街角等红绿灯，什么也没做。
And this guy like, hung out of the window of his car and yelled out, call me when you're legal. And it's just so weird. I mean, partially because I wasn't used to being a thing that you would want to have call you.
有个家伙把身子探出车窗大喊：“等你合法了再给我打电话。”这太诡异了。我的意思是，部分原因是我根本没习惯被人当作那种“应该打电话的对象”。
You mean specifically because you were a child?
你是说是因为你当时还是个孩子？
Yeah. Yeah. But also, because like what did he want there? What am I going to do in that scenario? Like, am I going to chase him? Am I going to actually give him my number so that he can call me in 11 years time when I am legal? Like, what's going to happen? What does he want there?
是的。对。但还有，他到底想要什么？那种情况下我能做什么？我该追上去吗？还是真的给他我的号码，让他等11年，等我合法后再打给我？到底会发生什么？他到底想要什么？
So the guy drove off. Eleanor grew up. And as an adult, she saw how often women are cat called, and she decided to do an experiment where she'd stop and talk to the guys, treat it like the beginning of a conversation. Like, OK, you wanted to talk? Let's talk. Ask some questions.
那个男人开车走了。埃莉诺长大了。成年后，她发现女性在街上被骚扰的频率很高，于是她决定做一个实验：停下来和这些男人交谈，把这当作一段对话的开始。就像是：好吧，你想搭讪？那我们就聊聊。问几个问题。
She took a recorder and a microphone. To increase the odds of getting catcalled, she ditched her normal clothes and her glasses for heels and lipstick. She lives in Australia, in Sydney, and she headed to an area called Kings Cross.
她带了一台录音机和麦克风。为了增加被搭讪的几率，她脱掉了平时的衣服和眼镜，换上了高跟鞋，涂上了口红。她住在澳大利亚的悉尼，去了国王十字区。
And it's like a night life spot anywhere else in the world. You don't need to have seen King's Cross to know what it's like. You have one wherever you live. It's billboards and like, fluorescent lights, and guys just kind of like shouting at the moon, and girls in tiaras and sashes on that say "18 Today!" with an exclamation mark.
那里和世界各地的夜生活区一样。你没去过国王十字区也能想象出那是什么样。你住的地方肯定也有一个。到处都是广告牌、霓虹灯，男人们对着月亮大喊大叫，女孩们戴着头冠，披着写有“今天18岁！”的绶带，后面还带着感叹号。
And I walked around, and whenever someone yelled out something, or catcalled, I would turn around, I would ask if I could start recording, and I would say, what did you just say, and what were you hoping to get from it?
我到处走，每当有人对我大喊大叫或搭讪时，我就会转身，问他们能不能录音，然后我会问：你刚才说了什么？你希望从中得到什么？
And most of them were like, pretty happy to talk. A lot of them were like, either drunk or just stoked that a girl was chatting to them. But they were pretty forthcoming.
大多数人很乐意交谈。很多人要么是喝醉了，要么就是因为有女孩跟他们聊天而感到兴奋。他们都很坦率。
OK. Let's hear some of the voices.
好吧。让我们听听其中一些人的声音。
So a guy just looks for a reaction, a smile, you're a dickhead, hi.
一个男人只是在寻找反应，一个微笑，你是混蛋，你好。
Just in case you're having trouble with the Australian accent, he's saying, "A guy just looks for a reaction, a smile, you're a dickhead, hi.
为了防止你们听不懂澳大利亚口音，他在说：“一个男人只是在寻找反应，一个微笑，你是混蛋，你好。”
A smile and you're a dickhead both equally good?
一个微笑和骂你是混蛋，效果一样好吗？
Both equally as good.
效果完全一样。
So it's just attention?
所以这只是为了引起注意？
No, no. It gives you a platform for you to start.
不，不。这为你提供了一个对话的平台。
How many successful relationships do you think have started from someone saying you're a dickhead?
你觉得有多少成功的恋爱关系是从对方说“你是个混蛋”开始的？
Zero.
零。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Describe this next guy.
描述一下下一个人。
And so this is Sebastian, and he's a bouncer with a strip club. He's kind of huge and stocky. He's wearing a baseball cap. And he shouted something at me about looking French, and he made this gesture as I walked past as if he was like, grabbing air breasts.
这是塞巴斯蒂安，他是脱衣舞俱乐部的保安。他身材魁梧。他戴着棒球帽。我经过时，他对我大喊大叫，说我看起来像法国人，还做了一个手势，好像在隔空抓揉乳房。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
Did you just make a gesture like breasts?
你刚才做了个抓胸部的动作吗？
I like saying hello to women. I like being friendly to women.
我喜欢跟女性打招呼。我喜欢对女性友好。
OK. So here's my thing, yeah?
好吧。这就是我的想法，明白吗？
They love it.
她们喜欢这样。
So you think that they're like--
所以你觉得她们是……
They have to.
她们必须喜欢。
Why?
为什么？
It's a nice thing when a man says hello.
男人打招呼是一件好事。
And one thing that started to emerge in every single one of these conversations was they think that women enjoy it. So whatever the first reason they gave for catcalling, almost immediately, the follow-up would be, and I want women to have a good time. I'm trying to make you feel good. I'm trying to give you a compliment, or make you feel confident. Women enjoy this, and that's part of why I do it. And that was astounding to me.
我在这些对话中发现了一个共同点，那就是他们认为女性很享受这种行为。所以无论他们给出的搭讪理由是什么，几乎紧接着他们就会说：“我是想让女性过得开心。我想让你感觉良好。我是在赞美你，或者想让你感到自信。女性很享受这些，这就是我这么做的部分原因。”这让我感到非常震惊。
So tell me about these guys.
跟我说说这些人。
This is Zac and Mike. Zac and Mike shouted at me as I was walking across an alleyway.
这是扎克和迈克。当我走过一条小巷时，扎克和迈克对我大喊大叫。
Do you want her to have fun, or are you just doing it for you?
你是希望她开心，还是只是为了你自己？
Oh, you know, I want her to get enjoyment out of what I yell at her. I don't want her to be-- in no way I want her to be offended, or feel in any way insecure about anything I say. It's always-- like, I'm never going to say anything rude or abusive. It's always for the good of the night.
哦，你知道的，我希望她能从我的喊叫中获得乐趣。我不希望她……我绝不希望她感到被冒犯，或者对我说的话感到不安。这总是……我从不说粗鲁或辱骂的话。这都是为了让夜晚更愉快。
OK. So it matters to you that she had fun?
好吧。所以她是否开心对你很重要？
Yeah. 100%.
是的。百分之百。
OK. And do you like-- do you count yourself as a good guy?
好吧。那你觉得自己是个好人吗？
Fucking oath, the best.
该死的，当然，我是最好的。
Fucking oath is Australian speak for like, hell yeah. These guys didn't seem like sexist nut jobs. That didn't seem unreasonable. They weren't hard to talk to. And it occurred to me they've just like, made a mistake. They just got some kind of central fact about women wrong, and they think that we really enjoy this.
“该死的”在澳大利亚口音里就像是“当然”的意思。这些人看起来不像性别歧视的疯子。他们看起来并不无理。和他们交谈并不难。我突然意识到，他们只是犯了个错。他们对女性的某种核心事实产生了误解，他们认为我们真的很享受这一切。
And surely, I can stand in front of these reasonable, caring dudes and just say women don't like it. And that might be a way of talking them out of doing it ever.
我想，我肯定能站在这些理性的、体贴的男人面前，告诉他们女性并不喜欢这样。这也许能劝说他们停止这种行为。
Eleanor, by the way, is in her 20s, and she spent 14 years in school as an unapologetic debate nerd, on debate teams, flying to Paris, and Doha, and Seoul, and Berlin to compete. As part of the national Australian debate team, she wore a blue Blazer with the Australian crest, so she is somebody who believes in her ability to persuade.
顺便提一下，埃莉诺才20多岁，她曾有14年的学生生涯，是辩论队的一员，参加过各种辩论赛，飞往巴黎、多哈、首尔和柏林参赛。作为澳大利亚国家辩论队的一员，她穿着印有澳大利亚徽章的蓝色西装外套，所以她是一个相信自己说服力的人。
And when she walked up to guys in the street with her recorder, she really did try to change the way they saw what they were doing. She really did try to convince them to change course and never catcall again. And that's when things got really interesting.
当她拿着录音机走向街上的男人时，她确实试图改变他们对这一行为的看法。她真的试图劝说他们改过自新，永远不要再搭讪。就在这时，事情变得非常有趣。
Today's program is all about people who believe in the power of a course correction, that they can get others to change course, or that they can get themselves to change course. And then, things will be fixed. The world will be a better place. They will be better people.
今天的节目是关于那些相信“纠正课程”力量的人，他们相信自己能让别人改变方向，或者能让自己改变方向。然后，一切都会好起来。世界会变得更好。他们会成为更好的人。
We have three stories, one about a US Marine, one about a robot, and we have Eleanor in King's Cross, who is Act One. Which is where we are now. This is actually a rerun of our show. But In these Harvey Weinstein, Louis C.K., Roy Moore days, we thought we'd go back to this story where a woman ties to talk-- sincerely talk-- to men about male behavior that she just does not understand.
我们有三个故事，一个是关于美国海军陆战队员的，一个是关于机器人的，还有一个就是我们现在的埃莉诺，这是第一幕。这实际上是我们节目的重播。但在哈维·温斯坦、路易·C·K、罗伊·摩尔这些天里，我们想回到这个故事，看看一个女性是如何试图——真诚地试图——与男性讨论她所无法理解的男性行为。
And I think the best way to illustrate what her conversations were like-- because they are really interesting-- is to play you excerpts of just one of them at length.
我认为展示这些对话最好的方式——因为它们真的很有趣——就是完整地播放其中一段片段。
And the one we're going to do is the conversation she had with Zac. Zac is the guy who was out with his friend Mike and said to her--
我们将播放的是她与扎克的对话。扎克就是那个和朋友迈克一起，对她说——
Like, I'm never going to say anything rude or abusive. It's always for the good of the night.
我从不说粗鲁或辱骂的话。这都是为了让夜晚更愉快。
Eleanor said Zac was a good listener. He seemed like a nice guy. And so this is how one of those conversations goes when it goes the best. Here's Eleanor.
埃莉诺说扎克是个很好的倾听者。他看起来是个好人。那么，当对话进展得最顺利时，情况是这样的。这是埃莉诺。
I talked to Zac and Mike in a dingy alley, which sounds scarier than it was, because it's hard to be scared of Zac and Mike. Zac's this big, friendly-looking overgrown teddybear of a man with huge brown eyes, and Mike's tiny and wiry. They look kind of like Yogi and Boo-Boo turned human. As I was walking past, Zac yells out, "Hey, luscious lips."
我和扎克及迈克在一条肮脏的小巷里谈话，这听起来比实际上更可怕，因为你很难对扎克和迈克感到害怕。扎克是一个身材高大、看起来很友善的男人，长着一双巨大的棕色眼睛，迈克则又瘦又小。他们看起来就像真人版的瑜伽熊和波波。当我走过时，扎克大喊：“嘿，性感的嘴唇。”
I was complimenting you on your red lips, how they look nice, and it would be amazing to kiss a complete stranger that worked for a radio station.
我是在赞美你那红润的嘴唇，它们看起来很漂亮，如果能吻到一个在电台工作的陌生人会很棒。
When Zac does this kind of stuff, it's like he's putting on our show. He's flirty. He's show-offy. His whole mission in life is to bring the party.
扎克做这种事时，就像是在表演节目。他很轻浮，喜欢炫耀。他的人生使命就是带给大家快乐。
If you've ever watched a documentary where you've got like, a bird, like an amazing bird, like the birds of paradise, they do the most extravagant dances, just amazing, just to flaunt themselves. I believe-- I know for a fact that saying crazy shit to girls, like the same sort of shit that I said that brought you to me right now, is the exact sort of same. It's kind of like being colorful with your words.
如果你看过关于鸟类的纪录片，比如天堂鸟，它们会跳出最夸张的舞蹈，真是太神奇了，只是为了炫耀自己。我相信——我敢肯定，对女孩说疯狂的废话，就像我刚才对你说的那些把你吸引到我身边的话一样，性质是一样的。这有点像是在言语上显得很出彩。
To be clear, I liked Zac, even when he told me this.
说清楚，即便他这么告诉我，我还是挺喜欢扎克的。
I've done rude things, like I've run along to groups of girls on the street, and like, complete random, and smacked one of their asses, like one out of about 10 . And all the rest are like, fixated on, oh, my god, why was her ass slapped? And it's enjoyable.
我也做过粗鲁的事，比如我跑向街上的女孩群，随手拍了其中一个的屁股，十个里面拍一个。剩下的那些女孩就会盯着看，天哪，为什么拍她屁股？这很有趣。
But it's only enjoyable, he says, if the woman's part of a group. He knows there's a line you don't cross. He's just drawn it in a weird place.
但他表示，只有当女性是一群人时才有趣。他知道有一条不能跨越的底线。他只是把它划在了奇怪的地方。
Yes, if you single out a girl and slap their ass, it can be a little bit creepy. But I wouldn't do that. I only slapped one ass of one group. I'm a one ass, one group guy. OK?
是的，如果你单独选一个女孩拍她们的屁股，那可能会有点变态。但我不会那样做。我只拍一群人里的一个屁股。我是个“一群人一个屁股”的男人。明白吗？
Would you have slapped my ass if I'd been closer to you?
如果我离你更近，你会拍我的屁股吗？
If you were in a group, yes. If you're on your own, no, I wouldn't.
如果你在人群中，会的。如果你是一个人，不会，我不会。
Why not if I was on my own?
为什么如果我是一个人就不会？
It kind of takes away the fun of it. The fun of it is your ass-- it's not saying your ass is not hot, but your ass is the hottest of the group. Therefore, I've slapped it.
这有点消除了乐趣。乐趣在于你的屁股——这并不是说你的屁股不性感，但你的屁股是那群人里最性感的。所以我拍了它。
Did anybody hit you, or yell at you, or tell you not to do that?
有人打你、对你大喊大叫，或者告诉你不要这样做吗？
No. No, no, no. I'm not doing anything wrong. I'm complimenting a girl's ass in public.
没有。不，不，不。我没做错什么。我是在公共场合赞美女孩的屁股。
You think that smacking a girl's ass in public isn't doing anything wrong?
你觉得在公共场合拍女孩的屁股没做错什么？
No.
不。
You can hear it, right? He sounds sincere. He wants to believe, or he really does, believe that this stuff is harmless, just a street show or a fun game for everyone to share.
你能听出来吧？他听起来很真诚。他想相信，或者他真的相信，这些行为是无害的，只是一个街头表演或每个人都能参与的有趣游戏。
Would it matter to you if what you did actually make girls feel really terrible? If I could convince you that at least some of us were made to feel small and frightened by guys who smack our asses on the street or give us compliments without asking, does that matter to you?
如果你的所作所为真的让女孩们感觉很糟糕，这对你来说重要吗？如果我能让你相信，我们中至少有一些人因为街上拍我们屁股或未经许可对我们评头论足的男人而感到渺小和恐惧，这对你来说重要吗？
Yeah, definitely. Fucking oath. I don't want anyone to feel uncomfortable or anything about my presence.
是的，当然。该死的，当然。我不希望任何人因为我的存在而感到不舒服。
OK. So here's a thought that I think maybe hasn't occurred to you. There's quite a lot of violence against women, right? Like, we understand that. One of the things that happens when you feel afraid as a chick, and you're just walking around and a guy slaps your ass, is you don't know if he intends it as a compliment or if he's actually really violent.
好吧。有个想法可能你还没想到。针对女性的暴力事件很多，对吧？我们都明白这一点。当你作为一个女孩感到害怕，只是在街上走着，却被一个男人拍了屁股时，你不知道他是真的在赞美你，还是真的有暴力倾向。
And so something that we do, something that we've learned to do, is to not reject men. One of the strategies we adopt is laugh, smile, be collegiate, be appeasing, be non-confrontational. Right? So I want to suggest to you that it's possible that a lot of the smiles and laughs that you see on the faces of the women who you slap or compliment are ways for them to get out of the situation rather than ways of thanking you.
所以我们学会的一种应对策略就是：不拒绝男人。我们采取的策略之一是：笑，微笑，表现得随和，表现得顺从，不要对抗。对吧？所以我想告诉你，你看到的那些被你拍打或赞美的女性脸上的笑容和笑声，很可能是她们为了脱身而做出的反应，而不是对你的感谢。
Well, I actually kind of feel a little bit bad now. Yeah, no, I do. Because I understand that. I understand that. That an ass slap cannot just be taken as a compliment.
好吧，我确实觉得有点难过。是的，不，我真的难过。因为我明白了。我明白了。拍屁股不能仅仅被视为一种赞美。
Zac seemed to get that. But then Mike explained that what I'd said didn't implicate them.
扎克似乎明白了。但随后迈克解释说，我说的话并不涉及他们。
Honestly, like, just because you feel that, and just because it's in the headlines, it does not mean that all chicks, all girls, have that same feeling. , Like every girl has a different level of sensitivity, and I'm feeling from you that your level of sensitivity is way higher, and there's a reason for why that is. And that's because of your upbringing or something in your past has brought you to feel this way.
老实说，仅仅因为你有这种感觉，仅仅因为这些出现在新闻标题里，并不意味着所有的女孩都有同样的感觉。每个女孩的敏感度不同，我感觉到你的敏感度要高得多，而且这背后是有原因的。那是因为你的成长经历或过去的某些事情让你有这种感觉。
In the end, they just weren't buying it. They kept coming back at me with variations on the same theme. Not all girls feel like you do, and we don't mean any harm. I just couldn't talk them out of it.
最终，他们根本听不进去。他们一直用同样的主题来反驳我。不是所有女孩都像你一样，我们没有恶意。我就是没法劝服他们。
Are you still going to yell at women on the street after talking to me?
跟我谈过之后，你还会对街上的女性大喊大叫吗？
Yes. I'm going to. Yes. Because--
会。我会的。是的。因为——
Even though it makes us feel bad.
即使这让我们感觉很糟糕。
But you can't speak for every girl.
但你不能代表每个女孩说话。
No, I can't. But I think it makes a reasonable proportion of us feel bad, and I think you taking the risk of frightening someone who something bad has happened to is an unkind thing to do.
不，我不能。但我认为这让相当一部分女性感到糟糕，而且我认为你冒着让那些曾遭受过伤害的人感到恐惧的风险，是一种不友善的行为。
Well, I'm sorry for being unkind, but I'm just another paradise bird flaunting my shit.
好吧，我为自己的不友善道歉，但我只是另一只炫耀羽毛的天堂鸟。
But you don't think that you can try and be better?
但你不觉得你可以尝试变得更好吗？
A better paradise bird?
成为一只更好的天堂鸟？
A better person?
成为一个更好的人？
It's true that I can't speak for other women, but I can speak to them. So just for the record, I went to check if I am the only one who feels this way. I talked to girls who are out, like out out, girls in sashes and tiaras and girls smoking outside clubs. And I asked them what they thought about catcalling.
我确实不能代表其他女性说话，但我可以和她们交流。为了记录在案，我去查了一下我是不是唯一一个有这种感觉的人。我和街上的女孩聊了聊，比如那些戴着头冠、穿着绶带的女孩，还有在俱乐部外抽烟的女孩。我问她们对搭讪的看法。
I hate it so much. It makes me feel so uncomfortable, pissed off, and scared. Shitty, but also super scared.
我非常讨厌它。这让我感到很不舒服、愤怒，而且恐惧。感觉很糟糕，但更多的是极度恐惧。
Just the idea that someone is so much bigger than me and could so easily do something to me. I feel cheap. I feel like I need to change my clothing, like I shouldn't have worn a dress today. I've never met like, a single person who enjoys it. Not even really drunk women like it, I don't think. I've never ever, ever met a girl that enjoyed it, ever.
一想到有人比我强壮得多，很容易对我做些什么，我就感到害怕。我觉得自己很廉价。我感觉我需要换衣服，觉得我今天就不该穿裙子。我从来没见过一个享受这种事的人。我觉得即使是喝醉的女性也不喜欢。我从来、从来、从来没见过一个享受这一点的女孩。
There was one woman who kind of enjoyed it. She was young and peppered with freckles, and just chilled out about everything.
有一个女人确实有点享受。她很年轻，长着雀斑，对一切都看得很开。
He complimented my butt, and I don't like my butt, so I was like, cool.
他赞美了我的屁股，而我不喜欢我的屁股，所以我当时想：酷。
By now, I was going kind of mad that I hadn't talked Zac out of cat-calling. I hate losing arguments. But more than that, I hate losing arguments for reasons I don't quite understand. And I still didn't understand Zac at all. Did he seriously just need evidence that more women felt like I did?
到现在，我因为没能说服扎克停止搭讪而感到有点抓狂。我讨厌输掉辩论。但更重要的是，我讨厌因为我不太理解的原因而输掉辩论。我还是根本不理解扎克。他难道真的需要证据来证明有更多女性有和我一样的感觉吗？
I decided to try persuading him a second time, only this time, I'd be armed with numbers. We met up again at 5 o'clock on a Wednesday, on the exact same spot where he yelled at me. On the night we'd met, there'd been vomit on the sidewalk, but by the middle of the week, it was just milk crates and cigarette butts.
我决定再次尝试说服他，但这次，我准备了数据。我们在周三下午5点又见了一次面，就在他对我大喊大叫的同一个地方。我们见面那天晚上，人行道上还有呕吐物，但到了周中，这里只剩板条箱和烟头了。
It took us a minute to recognize each other, but when we did, we sat side by side in the gutter and talked for an hour, conspicuously not touching elbows.
我们花了一分钟才认出对方，但当我们认出后，我们并排坐在排水沟旁聊了一个小时，刻意保持着距离，没有碰到胳膊。
All right. Let's talk about this slapping women on the ass thing.
好了。我们聊聊拍女人屁股这件事。
All right. [LAUGHING] Let's talk about it. You're sold on it. It's such a killer. It so works. You've just asked a question about a point--
好吧。[笑声] 我们聊聊吧。你对这个很执着。这真是个绝招。它太有效了。你刚才问的问题——
But you told me it doesn't work. You told me that I'm the first woman who's ever spoken to you after doing any of this stuff.
但你告诉我这没用。你告诉我，我是第一个在你做这种事后和你说话的女人。
Yeah, that's true. That's true. I was just being a smart ass. I'll just tell you like, other times it's happened. In Newtown once, it was Australia Day two years ago, I was with the same mate. And there was this group of like, English girls. I could hear their accent.
对，那是真的。那是真的。我刚才只是在装聪明。我告诉你其他发生过的例子。有一次在纽镇，那是两年前的澳大利亚日，我和同一个伙伴在一起。有一群英国女孩。我能听出她们的口音。
And I was like, fuck, fuck this. I'm going to fucking start with their asses. There's like, 10 of them. And I walked up in the middle of them, slapped one of the asses in the middle. Kind of like pushed my way through, and I just like started to impersonate them all.
我就想，去他的，我要去拍她们的屁股。她们大概有10个人。我走到她们中间，拍了中间一个的屁股。我有点像硬挤进去的，然后我开始模仿她们说话。
And they loved it. We ended up going to a pub and having drinks with them. But it didn't lead to anything more than that. But they like, thought that was cool. They were like, fucking, that's arrest worthy. You could get arrested for what you just did, but you did it. So fucking kudos to you. Come have a drink.
她们很喜欢。我们最后去了酒吧和她们喝了酒。虽然没发展出什么其他东西。但她们觉得这很酷。她们说：该死，这值得被捕。你刚才做的事会被捕的，但你真的做了。真厉害。来喝一杯。
The story that you just told me sounds like there was a group of women who were out by themselves, enjoying themselves. You ran into the middle of the group, you hit one of them without asking or speaking to her.
你刚才讲的故事听起来像是有一群女性独自在外，玩得很开心。你跑进人群中，未经允许或交流就拍了其中一个的屁股。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
That's not funny to me, man. What I'm trying to explain to you is that it's not just me who feels frightened at this stuff. And it's not just me who doesn't find it fun. I have some stats too. Hang on. So a survey found that 67% of women think that an interaction in the street, like a catcall or a slap, is going to escalate.
这对我来说并不好笑，伙计。我想向你解释的是，这不仅仅是我感到害怕。也不仅仅是我觉得没意思。我也有一些统计数据。等等。一项调查发现，67%的女性认为街上的互动，比如搭讪或拍屁股，会升级。
It's going to escalate to what?
升级到什么？
To a physical attack.
升级到身体攻击。
Something bad?
不好的事情？
Yeah.
对。
Oh, really? Fuck, that's bad.
哦，真的吗？该死，那很糟糕。
2/3 of women think that it's going to get worse.
2/3的女性认为情况会变得更糟。
That's really bad.
那真的很糟糕。
85% feel angry, 78% feel annoyed, 80% feel nervous, and 72% feel disgusted. It's not just me, man. Most of us hate it.
85%的人感到愤怒，78%感到厌烦，80%感到紧张，72%感到恶心。不只是我，伙计。我们大多数人都讨厌它。
Well, stats are stats, aren't they? Far out. I've never actually-- I've never heard any stats from it. I've just gone off face value from the situation. So, yeah, if you're asking me if I feel bad about what I've done, yeah, I feel bad if I've made anyone feel anything than like, kind of complimented. Yes, definitely.
好吧，数据就是数据，对吧？天哪。我从来没有——我从来没听过相关的统计数据。我只是根据当时的情况直观地判断。所以，是的，如果你问我是否对自己的行为感到难过，是的，如果我让任何人感到除了被赞美以外的任何不适，是的，我感到难过。绝对的。
Those odds suggest to me that you probably have made people feel angry and frightened.
这些概率向我表明，你很可能已经让人们感到愤怒和恐惧了。
I don't think I have. I honestly don't think I have, because I've seen the reaction. I'm not grabbing a chick's ass whatsoever. It's like a slap, it's like a tap. You know what I mean? A grab, I think that's a bit fucking weird. A dude going and grabbing a girl's arse, that's fucking wrong.
我不认为我有。我老实说我不认为我有，因为我看到了反应。我根本没有在抓女孩的屁股。那就像轻拍，就像拍一下。你明白吗？我觉得抓那是真他妈变态。一个男人去抓女孩的屁股，那是真他妈错误。
What makes it wrong to grab a girl's ass?
是什么让你觉得抓女孩的屁股是错误的？
Because you're like, you're fucking feeling their flesh and their body, and it's like, you could make them feel really uncomfortable. Like any--
因为你是在感受她们的皮肤和身体，这会让人感到非常不舒服。比如任何——
OK, but the things that make it wrong to grab someone, I'm telling you that's the same for slapping them.
好吧，但那些让你觉得抓别人是错误的理由，我告诉你，对于拍别人也是一样的。
But you can't speak for every girl, you know? You don't know--
但你不能代表每个女孩，你知道吗？你不知道——
Yes, we're back on this point. He was not budging on this. He came back to it over and over. He seemed to have this whole imagined world of women who were into this, and he wasn't ready to let it go.
是的，我们又回到这个问题了。他在这点上丝毫不让步。他一次又一次地回到这点。他似乎有一个关于女性的想象世界，认为她们很享受这一切，他还没准备好放弃这个想法。
What is it that you're thinking that makes you so reluctant to give it up?
是什么让你如此不情愿放弃这种想法？
'Cause I try and put myself in their position, and I try and imagine what it would be like to just be walking and have some compliment thrown at me by whoever. I would get some type of compliment out of it. If they'd had enough balls, or had enough beers, or fucking whatever to be able to yell something out, I'd be like, yeah, fucking whatever. Yeah, that's the way I try and like, look at things. How would I feel?
因为我试着站在她们的立场上，想象一下如果我走在路上，被任何人扔下一句赞美会是什么感觉。我能从中得到某种赞美。如果他们有足够的胆量，或者喝得够多，或者管他妈的什么原因能大喊出来，我会想：好吧，管他呢。是的，这就是我尝试看待事物的方式。我会是什么感觉？
So how would you feel if someone did what you do and slapped you on the ass without warning and without asking?
那么，如果有人做你做的事，毫无征兆且未经允许就拍你的屁股，你会是什么感觉？
I would feel a little bit special. If I was with a group of mates, I'd be like, ha, that's right. I've got a better ass than all you cunts.
我会觉得有点特别。如果我和一群哥们在一起，我会说：哈，那太对了。我的屁股比你们这些混蛋都好。
He just thinks it's nice to be noticed. Not intimidating, not scary. Just nice.
他只是认为被人注意到是一件好事。不是威慑，不是恐惧，只是好事。
Can I tell you I found this stuff really depressing?
能告诉你吗？我发现这一切真的很让人沮丧。
Depressing?
沮丧？
Yeah.
对。
Why?
为什么？
Because I feel like I've been walking around for days now believing that people want to be nice, and believing that it comes from a good place, and believing that guys are just trying to have fun and compliment people. But it's real, real hard for me to keep believing that when I tell people how angry it makes us, I tell people how sad it makes us, I tell people about sexual violence statistics, and the reaction isn't "that matters to me, and I'm going to stop." The reaction is, "That doesn't matter to me."
因为我觉得我已经在大街上走了好几天，一直相信人们想要友善，相信这些源于好意，相信男人们只是想找乐子并赞美别人。但当我告诉人们这让我们多么愤怒，多么悲伤，当我告诉他们关于性暴力的统计数据，而反应不是“这对我来说很重要，我会停止”，而是“这对我来说不重要”，这让我很难再继续相信这些。
And it makes me feel like I'm walking around begging people to take people like me seriously, and they're choosing their fun over how I feel. It makes me feel so small.
这让我觉得自己走在街上是在乞求人们认真对待像我这样的人，而他们却为了自己的快乐而无视我的感受。这让我感到如此渺小。
I know. That's fucked. That's fucked. Well, that's kind of just the selfishness of the world. People know how fucked up-- how bad of things have happened to people. But it's still not going to hinder the way that they are or anything like that. That's just like human selfishness.
我懂。这真该死。这太糟糕了。好吧，这只是世界的自私。人们知道这种糟糕的事情发生过，但这仍然不会阻止他们成为他们那样的人。这就是人类的自私。
But I don't want to talk about humans and selfishness. I want to talk about you.
但我不想谈论人类和自私。我想谈谈你。
OK. [LAUGHING]
好的。[笑声]
You going to stop? 'Cause I'm not playing.
你会停止吗？因为我没在开玩笑。
Yes. I'm not going to slap any more asses. Compliments when I feel they are appropriate, and they're not too suggestive in any way, they're very lighthearted, I think I'm still going to do.
会。我不会再拍任何人的屁股了。当我感到适当，且方式并不露骨，只是非常轻松的时候，我想我可能还是会赞美。
Can you shake my hand and promise me you won't slap any more asses?
你能跟我握手并保证不会再拍任何人的屁股吗？
Yes, I can shake your hand. I can shake your hand. I am not going to slap any more asses.
好的，我可以跟你握手。我可以跟你握手。我不会再拍任何人的屁股了。
After he left, I sat on the curb surrounded by fossilized bits of chewing gum and watched the traffic go by. This was the most success I had with any of the guys I talked to. It took 120 minutes of conversation with one man to get him to commit to not literally assaulting women.
他走后，我坐在马路牙子上，周围是被踩扁的口香糖残渣，看着车流驶过。这是我与谈过的所有人中最成功的一次。我和一个男人谈了120分钟，才让他承诺不去真正地猥亵女性。
Eleanor Gordon Smith. She teaches ethics at the University of Sydney.
埃莉诺·戈登·史密斯。她在悉尼大学教授伦理学。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Act Two, "The Real Decoy." So now we turn to the story of a man who had always had one way of doing things and talking to people. And then he did not need a stranger on the street to walk up to him with a microphone. He noticed this on his own, that the way he was dealing with people had stopped working the way it always had, and he made some adjustments. Stephanie Foo tells what happened.
第二幕，“真正的诱饵”。现在我们要讲述一个男人，他一直有一种做事和与人交谈的方式。然后，他不需要一个街上的陌生人拿着麦克风向他走来。他自己注意到了，他与人交往的方式已经不再奏效了，于是他做了一些调整。斯蒂芬妮·傅讲述了发生的事情。
Michael Pitre was always the new kid growing up . He went to 10 schools in five states. But he generally did OK, because he's always been good at telling stories. Even now, he's got a solid arsenal.
迈克尔·皮特雷在成长过程中一直是“新来的孩子”。他在五个州读过10所学校。但他总体上做得不错，因为他一直很擅长讲故事。即使现在，他也有丰富的库存。
Do you want to hear Fred the Scorpion? That's another one of the greatest hits.
你想听“蝎子弗雷德”吗？那是另一个最热门的故事。
I--
我——
Do you want to hear something else? Want to hear another funny one?
你想听别的吗？想听另一个有趣的？
I actually-- I'm running out of time a little bit.
其实——我的时间有点不够了。
Mike is like this wherever he is-- at home, at work. In 2006 and 2007, Mike served two tours in Iraq, and he had a rep there as the storyteller, the funny guy. Joslyn Hemler was in the Marine Corps with them, and I asked her about turnover briefs.
迈克无论在哪里都是这样——在家、在工作。2006年和2007年，迈克两次被派往伊拉克，他在那里以故事大王、幽默达人的身份闻名。乔斯林·海姆勒和他一起在海军陆战队服役，我问了她关于交接简报的事。
Mike ran all the operations for his battalion overnight, and in the morning had to give a briefing of the events of the past 12 hours.
迈克整晚负责营里的所有行动，早上还要进行过去12小时的简报。
Turnover briefs are one of those monotonous things we probably do. So very matter of fact, very military. But Mike, it somehow turned into like, a quasi like, soap opera of events. He'd be like, sitting in this rolling chair, he'd have one of those extended pointers. And he'd be like, let's go to the map. And he'd like, roll all the way across the watch floor. Like, he just gave such rich detail to the story.
交接简报通常是我们做的最枯燥的事情之一。所以非常公事公办，非常军事化。但迈克不知怎么把它变成了某种肥皂剧。他会坐在那张转椅上，拿着那种伸缩指示棒。他会说：“让我们看地图。”然后他会直接滚过整个观察室。他给故事增添了极其丰富的细节。
A lot of times, he's looking for validation when he tells his stories, which are funny. He'll be like, that was funny, right?
很多时候，他在讲那些有趣的故事时是在寻求认可。他会说：那很有趣吧，对吧？
Mike came back stateside after his first deployment, and he was visiting his parents on New Year's Eve, as some kids were shooting fireworks.
迈克在第一次部署后回到国内，新年夜去探望父母时，一些孩子正在放烟花。
I said, yeah, those fireworks look like airburst mortars. And my brother said, oh, did you see any airburst mortars? I mean, a question as innocuous as that.
我说：“是啊，那些烟花看起来像空爆迫击炮。”我哥哥说：“哦，你见过空爆迫击炮吗？”我的天，这样一个极其普通的问题。
So Mike did what he'd always done. He started telling the first story that popped into his head on the subject.
于是迈克做了他一贯的做法。他开始讲脑海中蹦出来的第一个关于这个话题的故事。
And I started talking about-- there was this one day I was running on this large base where I was stationed, and a volley of airburst mortars came in. And where they went off, right underneath them was a Naval officer, and she took a piece of shrapnel right through her neck, right in front of me and these three other Marines.
我开始讲述——有一天我在我驻扎的大基地里跑步，一轮空爆迫击炮打了进来。就在它们爆炸的地方，下面正好是一名海军军官，她就在我和其他三名陆战队员面前，被一块弹片穿透了脖子。
And she is dying, she is bleeding to death, and she is scared. And it's me and these three Marines getting her into the back of a Humvee, and she's telling us what to tell her kids. And telling that to my family--
她正在死去，正在流血致死，而且她很害怕。是我和另外三名陆战队员把她抬进悍马车后座，她告诉我们要转告她孩子们什么话。把这些讲给我的家人听——
What did their faces look like as you were saying it?
你讲这些时，他们脸上的表情是什么样的？
Just sort of shocked and horrified. And you don't ever want your family to look at you with shock and horror. That's not fun.
就是那种震惊和恐惧。你永远不希望你的家人用震惊和恐惧的眼神看你。那一点也不好玩。
Mike told his family, by the way, she wound up being OK. The officer survived. But that didn't lighten the mood. And he couldn't figure out how to save the moment. That was new and weird.
顺便说一句，迈克告诉家人，她最终没事。那位军官活了下来。但那并没有缓解气氛。他无法弄清楚如何拯救当时的局面。那是新鲜且诡异的。
This happened a few more times when he was home between deployments. His best friend Brock asked him about IEDs. And he answered honestly. They never talked about IEDs again after that. Other friends on other nights at other bars asked about Iraqis or politics.
他在部署间隙回家时，这种情况又发生了几次。他最好的朋友布洛克问他关于IED（简易爆炸装置）的事。他诚实地回答了。那之后他们再也没谈过IED的事。其他朋友在其他夜晚、其他酒吧问起伊拉克人或政治。
And so the first time your friends from back home ask you, you answer the question very, very honestly. And you realize that halfway through your answer, that you're making everyone very uncomfortable. And it's almost like the air between you starts to thicken. It's almost a physical feeling of people withdrawing from you.
所以，当老家的朋友第一次问你时，你非常非常诚实地回答了问题。然后你意识到在回答到一半时，你让每个人都非常不舒服。空气仿佛都凝固了。那是一种人们退缩的物理感觉。
What are they supposed to do? What are they supposed to say to you? They have nothing to say to you. And also, what are they thinking about me right now?
他们应该做什么？他们应该对你说什么？他们对你无话可说。而且，他们现在在想我什么？
What were you afraid that they were thinking about you?
你害怕他们想你什么？
That I was damaged. That I had nothing else to talk about. That I was a violent person. That I wasn't a normal person. And if you say I don't want to talk about it, then you're the truculent vet who is going to be sitting brooding in the corner, and that carries its own stigma.
觉得我受损了。觉得我没别的话可聊。觉得我是一个暴力的人。觉得我不是个正常人。如果你说不想聊这个，那你就是那个倔强的退伍军人，坐在角落里沉思，这本身就带有污名。
We think that it's like, oh, it's because you're so damaged.
我们认为，噢，这是因为你太受损了。
Right. You have a shattered psyche. You must.
没错。你的心理破碎了。肯定是的。
But you're like, no, it's because I'm trying to protect your psyche.
但你会说：不，这是因为我在试图保护你们的心理。
I want to protect the conversation. I think what people hear sometimes is "I don't want to talk about it because it bothers me so much." And sometimes it's, "I don't want to talk about it because it's going to bother you, and you don't even know it."
我想保护对话。我认为人们有时听到的是：“我不想谈，因为这让我太烦恼了。”而有时其实是：“我不想谈，因为这会让你烦恼，而你甚至还没意识到。”
He learned to shut up about that stuff. Not that people stopped asking. Like he was out with friends, and someone asked him about mortars again. And even though, of course, the first story that popped into his head was about the officer who got shrapnel in her neck, it was like he went on to the next slide. Tried something different. And he blurted out--
他学会了闭嘴不谈这些事。并不是人们不再问了。就像他和朋友出去时，有人又问他关于迫击炮的事。尽管他脑子里蹦出的第一个故事显然是关于脖子被弹片击中的军官，但他就像跳到了下一张幻灯片。尝试了一些不同的做法。他脱口而出——
Well, you know, you have to get a good poo on the mortar. They're like, oh, what, a poo on the mortar? It's like, yeah, the point of origin.
嗯，你知道，你得查清迫击炮的POO（发射点）。他们说：哦，什么，迫击炮的排泄物（poo）？他说：是的，发射点。
Basically, they can trace where an enemy mortar's launched from. Its point of origin, POO.
基本上，他们可以追踪敌方迫击炮是从哪里发射的。它的发射点，即POO。
So everyone just refers very casually to a mortar's POO. And then in the command center, there's like wall maps, where there's an officer in charge of marking every POO in-- no kidding-- a little brown marker.
所以每个人都非常随意地提到迫击炮的POO。然后在指挥中心，有壁挂式地图，负责标记每一个POO的军官会用——不是开玩笑——一支棕色小记号笔标记。
And there was this place to the northeast of Fallujah. It's a bend in the river. Topographically, it looked like a scrotum. So everyone called it the ball sack. And that's the place where most of the mortars were launched. And so, you'd see your old friends on the base. And you'd say, what are you up to these days? And they go, oh, you know, I'm just POO hunting in the ball sac. Yeah, be careful. Ball sac's no joke.
在费卢杰东北部有个地方。那是河的一个弯道。地形看起来像个阴囊。所以大家都叫它“蛋蛋袋”。那里是大多数迫击炮发射的地方。所以，当你看到基地里的老朋友时。你会问：最近忙什么呢？他们会说：哦，你知道，我只是在蛋蛋袋里搜寻POO。是的，小心点。蛋蛋袋可不是开玩笑的。
He was back, the funny guy. The guy people actually wanted to be around. And it was easy. Mike started getting better at using questions to pivot to funny military stories. Like when people asked about helicopters, he talked about how a friend's epic farts would stink up the whole bird.
他又变回了那个有趣的家伙。大家真正愿意接近的那种人。而且这很容易。迈克开始擅长利用问题来引出有趣的军事故事。比如当人们问起直升机时，他就聊起朋友的史诗级屁是怎么让整个舱室发臭的。
Did it feel like you were connecting with people?
你觉得你是在和人建立联系吗？
Yes. It is euphoric. It was great for years. It felt great. There was an element of relief in having solved the problem.
是的。那种感觉是欣快。这很好，持续了好多年。感觉很棒。解决这个问题有一种解脱感。
Yeah.
是的。
That's what an officer does. You're handed a problem. In the military, it's called a mission. You design the solution to it, and you execute it.
这就是军官所做的。你被交办一个问题。在军事上，这被称为任务。你设计解决方案，然后执行。
It was around this time that Mike met Erin. She was a friend of his little sister's, and they'd started emailing each other during his first deployment. And he developed a huge crush, even though he'd never met her in person.
就在那时，迈克遇到了艾琳。她是迈克小妹妹的朋友，他们在迈克的第一次部署期间开始互发邮件。他暗恋上了她，尽管从未见过面。
So now that he was home, he finally went out with her and a bunch of her friends. So they're out, and someone brought up the Iraqis. Said, are they even doing anything for themselves over there? This was such a cartoonish idea of the war, it annoyed Mike. And without thinking, he found himself telling a story to prove how seriously the Iraqi army took their jobs, a story where in order to find a terrorist, the Iraqi army rounded up all the men in a village, bound them, and put them on their knees with their heads against the wall. That's how seriously they took this.
所以现在他回家了，他终于和她以及她的一群朋友出去玩。他们在外面，有人提到了伊拉克人。说：他们在那里真的在为自己做点什么吗？这对于战争是一个非常卡通的想法，让迈克很烦。他没多想，发现自己在讲一个故事，为了证明伊拉克军队有多认真对待工作，故事内容是：为了找到恐怖分子，伊拉克军队把村里所有的男人抓起来，捆住，让他们跪在墙边。这就是他们对待这项工作的认真程度。
He stopped talking and realized, crickets. He looked up at Erin. She was horrified. And he thought, oh god, oh god. I've got to tell a funny story now. So he launched into one of his classics, Fred the Scorpion, which goes like this.
他停下谈话，意识到：鸦雀无声。他抬头看艾琳。她被吓坏了。他想：天哪，天哪。我得讲个有趣的故事了。于是他开始了经典故事之一，“蝎子弗雷德”，内容是这样的。
So my first deployment, I was a platoon commander. And some of my Marines found a scorpion. And that's a big deal. You can feed it vermin. You can fight it against other scorpions owned by other platoons.
我第一次部署时，是排长。我的一些陆战队员发现了一只蝎子。这可是大事。你可以用害虫喂它。你可以让它和其他排拥有的蝎子打架。
So this scorpion, unbeknownst to me, kind of became the platoon mascot, and they kept it in a cardboard box in their barracks, right underneath someone's bed.
所以这只蝎子，我不知道，成了排里的吉祥物，他们把它关在营房的一个纸箱里，就在某人的床底下。
Mike finds out about the scorpion. Turns out, it's one of the most deadly species in the world. He's their boss, so he orders them to kill it. But everybody is really attached to Fred, so they come up with this crazy plan to euthanize him.
迈克发现了蝎子的事。结果发现，这是世界上最致命的品种之一。他是他们的上司，所以他命令他们杀死它。但每个人都对弗雷德产生了深厚感情，所以他们想出了这个疯狂的计划来安乐死它。
They dropped him into a bucket of diesel fuel for, I think, three days. And he's all shriveled up, and everyone's pretty convinced he's dead. They pick him up, he springs back to life, and he runs off into the desert.
我想，他们把它扔进了一桶柴油里，大概三天。它缩成一团，所有人都确信它死了。他们把它捡起来，它竟然死而复生，逃进了沙漠。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Yeah, Fred the Scorpion. I miss him.
是啊，蝎子弗雷德。我很想念它。
OK. So Fred the Scorpion.
好吧。这就是蝎子弗雷德。
Yeah. It goes over great.
是的。效果很好。
Is it a decoy for another story that is real?
这是另一个真实故事的诱饵吗？
Yeah. And the story-- so there was a curfew at night in the surrounding communities, like [INAUDIBLE], and Fallujah, and Ramadi. So people couldn't drive at night.
是的。那个故事——当时周边社区有宵禁，比如[听不清]、费卢杰和拉马迪。所以人们晚上不能开车。
Power was intermittent, and it was hot. Some Iraqi families would sleep on the roof at night to keep cool. It wasn't unheard of for kids to get stung by scorpions up there.
电力是断断续续的，而且天气很热。一些伊拉克家庭晚上会在屋顶睡觉以保持凉爽。孩子们在那里被蝎子蜇伤并不是什么闻所未闻的事。
And they would be faced with the decision of, do we get in our car and try to take our child to get medical help and risk getting shot? And that's something I heard all the time from Iraqis. What do we do if our child is dying of a scorpion bite? Can we violate curfew then?
他们将面临抉择：我们要开车带孩子去看病，冒着被枪杀的风险吗？这是我从伊拉克人那里经常听到的。如果我们的孩子被蝎子咬伤快死了，我们该怎么办？那时我们可以违反宵禁吗？
The curfew was imposed by the Americans. And he couldn't promise that an Iraqi family traveling to the hospital to save their kid would not get shot by Americans who were trying to protect themselves from suicide bombers. So when Iraqis asked him this question?
宵禁是美国人实施的。他无法保证一个去医院救孩子的伊拉克家庭不会被那些试图保护自己免受自杀式炸弹袭击的美国人枪杀。所以当伊拉克人问他这个问题时？
The answer you want to give them is, yes, please, bring us your kid. Let us help. The actual answer is you're taking your life in your hands. And so that's the story you don't want to tell. Yeah, scorpions are not just this innocuous-- a scorpion bite for an Iraqi family causes an impossible decision and puts Marines in impossible situations. And for years, we were faced with that.
你想给出的答案是：是的，请带上你的孩子。让我们帮忙。但实际的答案是：你在拿自己的生命冒险。这就是那个你不想讲的故事。是的，蝎子对于伊拉克家庭来说不仅仅是无害的——蝎子咬伤会导致绝望的抉择，并让陆战队员陷入绝望的境地。多年来，我们一直面临这种情况。
But Fred the Scorpion, the decoy story, worked. Everyone at the table laughed. Erin relaxed. Two months later, she quit her job and moved across the country to be with him.
但蝎子弗雷德，那个诱饵故事，奏效了。桌上的每个人都笑了。艾琳放松了。两个月后，她辞职并搬到全国各地和他在一起。
Nearly 10% of Americans served in the Second World War. Back then, you very likely had a co-worker, a son, a neighbor who was serving in the war effort. In Vietnam, far fewer served. 2% of the population. Today, only about half a percent of our population has served in Iraq and Afghanistan, experiencing something that's mostly invisible to the rest of us.
近10%的美国人参加了第二次世界大战。那时，你很可能有个同事、儿子或邻居正在为战争出力。在越南战争中，参战人数要少得多。占人口的2%。今天，只有大约0.5%的美国人参加过伊拉克和阿富汗战争，经历了一些对我们大多数人来说几乎不可见的事情。
So when people ask these seemingly simple questions about the war at a Christmas party, vets today have to figure out how to communicate this very large, nuanced, morally complicated thing to people who are probably coming to the conversation knowing nothing at all. Silence is an option a lot of vets go with. There's also dodging the question entirely, or the whole gory shock and awe method. The funny stories work around was Mike's solution. And for years, it worked. Sort of. There was a downside.
所以当人们在圣诞派对上问这些关于战争的看似简单的问题时，今天的退伍军人必须找出如何将这种非常宏大、细腻、道德复杂的议题传达给那些对此一无所知的人。保持沉默是许多退伍军人的选择。还有完全回避问题，或者采取那种血腥的“震惊与敬畏”方法。讲有趣的故事是迈克的解决方案。而且多年来，它奏效了。某种程度上。有一个负面影响。
Mike came home from his final deployment in 2007. Then he and Erin moved to Louisiana to start their lives together. Both of them went back to school, they held dinner parties, went to shows. Everything seemed fantastic. But Erin was disturbed by the fact that Mike could be distant.
迈克于2007年结束最后一次部署回家。然后他和艾琳搬到了路易斯安那州开始他们的生活。他们都回到学校，举办晚宴，去看演出。一切看起来都很棒。但艾琳对迈克有时会变得疏离感到不安。
Every once in a while, when he got really drunk, he'd lose his temper and start yelling. He often couldn't sleep and had trouble making friends. At those dinner parties, he could still make people laugh by telling those funny stories about the war. But Erin says they were always the same few stories, and he'd just held them over and over and over again. Here's Erin.
偶尔，当他喝得很醉时，他会失去控制并开始大喊大叫。他经常睡不着觉，也很难交到朋友。在那些晚宴上，他仍然可以通过讲那些战争中有趣的故事让人们发笑。但艾琳说那总是同样的那几个故事，他翻来覆去讲了又讲。这是艾琳。
I could recognize that it was a mask, that it wasn't the real thing. I mean, he was vaudeville. You know, and I was guilty of being like, Mike, tell us. Tell us the time with the POO.
我能看出那是一个面具，那不是真实的他。我的意思是，他就像个杂耍艺人。你知道，我也曾犯过错，说：“迈克，给我们讲讲吧。给我们讲讲那个关于POO的故事。”
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
But like, I would hear people ask him questions. And I would catch him telling decoy stories. I think he just wanted a break, and he wanted to live, and he wanted to be happy, which was OK. Until it wasn't.
但我会听到人们问他问题。我会发现他在讲诱饵故事。我想他只是想休息一下，他想生活，他想快乐，这没问题。直到有一天出了问题。
A couple of years later, on a chilly evening, one of Mike's best friends from college visited the two of them in Louisiana. The friend was spending the night, and they were all on his porch at 2:00 AM drinking. His friend was talking.
几年后，在一个寒冷的夜晚，迈克的一位最好的大学朋友到路易斯安那州拜访他们。朋友在那里过夜，他们都在凌晨2点在门廊上喝酒。朋友在说话。
And I think he kind of said almost apropos of nowhere, you know 5,000 people dying in a war is not really that much, historically speaking. And I lost control of myself. Before I knew it, I was in his face screaming with a finger pointed right at his face, and I had to be physically pulled away by two other people who were there.
我想他不知怎么地说了一句，差不多是突然冒出来的：你知道，历史上5000人在战争中死亡并不是什么大事。我失去了控制。在我意识到之前，我就已经冲到他面前，手指指着他的脸大叫，最后被在场的另外两个人强行拉开。
I think what I was screaming at him was, yeah, 5,000 Americans, but you don't care at all about the 100,000 Iraqis, do you? Is that what you're telling me?
我想我当时对他大喊的是：是的，5000名美国人，但你一点也不在乎10万伊拉克人，对吧？这就是你要告诉我的吗？
Actually, the number is really in dispute. You see estimates between 115,000 and 500,000 deaths.
事实上，死亡数字确实存在争议。你看到的估计数字在11.5万到50万之间。
Do you think that your friend might have been more careful with his choice of words if you had not projected a level of chill about your experiences, you know?
你觉得如果你没有表现出对你的经历如此冷漠，你的朋友会不会在措辞上更谨慎一些？
That's absolutely correct. Yeah. Yeah, my friend would have been more careful with his words had I not had such a perfectly cultivated veneer of chill that I'd spent years creating.
那绝对正确。是的。是的，如果我没有那样多年精心营造出来的冷漠外壳，我的朋友会在用词上更谨慎的。
This kind of thing had happened a couple of times before, but this incident was the worst, and Erin was worried. She was the only person who knew how much he was suppressing. Because during Mike's second deployment, he'd handwritten her a letter every day telling her the truth, and his feelings about it, his fear, his grief.
这种事以前发生过几次，但这次事件是最糟糕的，艾琳很担心。她是唯一知道他压抑了多少的人。因为在迈克第二次部署期间，他每天都给她写信，告诉她真相，以及他的感受，他的恐惧，他的悲伤。
But once he came home, Mike never mentioned any of these things again, not even to Erin. Whenever she tried to ask a question about them, he just said, my friends died there, so I don't want to talk about it. So the morning after Mike's outburst with his friend, Erin cornered Mike and told him, look, this is happening because you haven't told a real story about the war in years.
但一旦他回家，迈克就再也没提过这些事，即使是对艾琳。每当她试图问相关问题时，他总是说：“我的朋友死在那里，所以我不想谈论它。”所以迈克和朋友爆发冲突的第二天早上，艾琳把迈克逼到了角落告诉他：看，这之所以会发生，是因为你多年来都没讲过一个真实的关于战争的故事。
The night before, which I was gone completely out of control, she was like, well, at least you were being real with him last night. At least you respect him that much.
昨晚，我彻底失控了，她说：好吧，至少你昨晚对他表现得很真实。至少你尊重他到了那个地步。
And how did you respond?
你是怎么回应的？
Uh, I don't think I did. She had me. She was right. There was no response to that.
呃，我不认为我有回应。她抓住了我。她是正确的。对此无言以对。
Mike had thought the decoy stories had brought him closer to people. But he was now realizing, it might have been doing just the opposite.
迈克曾以为那些诱饵故事让他与人拉近了距离。但他现在意识到，情况可能恰恰相反。
That's not a good feeling when you can't even communicate to someone the stories that are actually significant to you. You deceive them. You're lying to them. You're telling a story that's true, but that's not the story you want to tell.
当你甚至不能向人传达那些对你真正重要的故事时，这种感觉并不好。你在欺骗他们。你在对他们撒谎。你在讲一个真实的故事，但这并不是你想讲的故事。
And over time, people think they know more and more about you, when they know less and less. And your friendships become kind of threadbare.
随着时间的推移，人们以为他们对你了解得越来越多，而其实他们了解的越来越少。而你们的友谊也变得有点破烂不堪。
Like his friendship with his best friend, Brock, who he'd known since he was 16. Brock was the one who asked him about the IEDs when he got back. And since then, he hadn't told him anything except decoy stories. But Brock did still ask questions. So the next time Brock asked a real question, Mike tried something different.
就像他和他最好的朋友布洛克的友谊，他从16岁就认识他了。布洛克就是在他回来时问他IED问题的那个人。从那以后，他除了诱饵故事什么也没告诉过他。但布洛克确实还在问问题。所以当布洛克下次问一个真正的问题时，迈克尝试了一些不同的做法。
He'd read an article about the recovery of bodies on the battlefield. And he wanted to know about how that worked. So I told him how that worked, how if there's a dead body, what the procedures are for removing them.
他读过一篇文章，关于战场上的尸体回收。他想知道那是怎么运作的。所以我告诉了他那是怎么运作的，如果有尸体，移除它们的程序是什么。
The details of those types of procedures are horrible. So I told him one of the things you have to do sometimes is post a marine with a rifle to shoot dogs who are coming to try to carry away pieces of your dead friends. I told him that. And it was fine. And I realized it was fine, that I could talk to him.
那些程序细节很可怕。所以我告诉他，有时你必须做的一件事是派一名带步枪的陆战队员去射杀那些试图跑来叼走你死去的战友肢体的野狗。我告诉了他。结果没事。我意识到没关系，我能和他交谈。
What made it fine?
是什么让这一切变得没关系？
What Brock did that was so important and so good, he didn't say anything about it. He just looked me in the eye until I was done.
布洛克做的那件事非常重要且非常好，他对此什么也没说。他只是看着我的眼睛，直到我说完。
He was signaling that he was willing to listen.
他是在传达他愿意倾听的信号。
Yeah, and that he was not-- because when you see a monster, you look away. But he just kept looking at me in the eye.
是的，他并不是——因为当你看到怪物时，你会移开目光。但他只是直视我的眼睛。
Since then, Mike has shared much more with the people he cares about.
从那以后，迈克和他在意的人分享了更多。
So, do you still tell decoys now?
所以，你现在还会讲诱饵故事吗？
All the time. Yeah. Want to hear another one?
一直都在讲。是的。想听另一个吗？
Sure. Of course I want a decoy story.
当然。我当然想听诱饵故事。
So I had this battalion executive officer, who--
所以我有这个营部的执行官，他——
The difference is now, he doesn't only tell decoy stories. He says when he decides which kind of story to tell, sometimes he thinks about the sign that used to hang above the door to the operations center in Iraq. It read, "What do I know, who needs to know it, and have I told them." And then, he begins his story.
不同的是现在，他不只讲诱饵故事。他说，当他决定讲哪种故事时，有时他会想到过去挂在伊拉克作战中心门上的那个牌子。上面写着：“我知道什么，谁需要知道，我已经告诉他们了吗。”然后，他开始讲他的故事。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program. Regarding her story, Michael Pitre has written a novel. Stephanie says it's really good. It's called "Fives and 25's," which follows a group of Marines during and after the Iraq War. We'll have a link to it at our website.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制作人之一。关于她的故事，迈克尔·皮特雷写了一本小说。斯蒂芬妮说那真的很好。书名是《5和25》，讲述了一群陆战队员在伊拉克战争期间及之后的故事。我们网站上会有链接。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Coming up, a robot tries to get with the program. Get it? Get with the program? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一个机器人试图配合这个程序。懂吗？配合程序？稍后播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
"This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Once More With Feeling," stories of people who decide to rethink the way they've been doing things. We'll try to get others to do that.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带来关于这个主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《再次感受》，讲述人们决定重新思考他们做事方式的故事。我们也会尝试让其他人这样做。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "You Had One Job." So we're going to end today's show with a machine, a machine that always does things the same way, because machines are designed and programmed to always do things the same way.
我们的节目进入了第三幕。第三幕，“你只有一个任务”。所以我们要以一个机器结束今天的节目，一个总是以同样方式做事机器，因为机器被设计和编程为总是以同样方式做事。
This is a piece of fiction from somebody who's a journalist and a TV writer, named Scott Brown. This story was read for by actor Jeremy Shamos.
这是一篇虚构作品，来自一位记者兼电视编剧，名叫斯科特·布朗。这个故事由演员杰里米·沙莫斯朗读。
I have one arm, because my job only takes one arm to do. And I only have one job. I like my job so much. The other officers at precinct nine don't know I like it. They don't know I like anything.
我只有一只手臂，因为我的工作只需要一只手臂。而且我只有一个任务。我非常喜欢我的工作。九号分局的其他警官不知道我喜欢它。他们不知道我喜欢任何东西。
I like them, though, especially my operator, Officer Brian Parisse, who the other officers call Gamergate, Indoor Kid, and Tech Support, and whom I called Brian, but not out loud, because I can only say three things out loud-- "Stay Back 1,000 Feet," "Follow Officer's Instructions," "You are in the blast zone."
不过我喜欢他们，尤其是我的操作员，布莱恩·帕里斯警官，其他警官叫他“玩家门”、“室内小孩”和“技术支持”，我叫他布莱恩，但不是大声叫，因为我大声只能说三句话——“保持1000英尺距离”、“遵循警官指示”、“你处在爆炸区”。
When I'm not doing my job, which is most of the time, I'm in the break room. I'm supposed to be in the vehicle bay, but someone thought it would be funny to put me in the break room, next to the coffee machine wearing a Carolina Panthers hat. The hat is to differentiate me from the coffee machine.
当我没工作时，大多数时间都在休息室里。我应该在车辆库，但有人觉得把我放在休息室，咖啡机旁边，戴着卡罗莱纳黑豹队帽子会很有趣。这帽子是为了把我与咖啡机区分开。
That's a joke. I am nothing like the coffee machine. It weighs nine pounds. I weigh 900. It has rubber nubs for feet and doesn't move. I have six prehensile AT treads, and can travel up to 18 miles per hour, and I have a hat. My arm's been outstretched so I can give high fives and handshakes. Officers love those. In exchange, they give me a "What up, MILES?" or a "Peace out, MILES."
这是个笑话。我一点也不像咖啡机。它重9磅。我重900磅。它有橡胶脚垫不会动。我有六条预抓式AT履带，时速可达18英里，而且我还有一顶帽子。我的手臂一直伸着，所以我可以击掌和握手。警官们喜欢这些。作为交换，他们会对我喊“怎么了，MILES？”或者“再见，MILES”。
I'm MILES, and I'm very good at handshakes. Just OK at high-fives. Getting better at fist bumps. I can live with the hat. I know the hat looks stupid because my eye is better than the officers know, and because I have limited learning, a software upgrade only Brian knows about, and because there's a mirror in the break room.
我是MILES，我非常擅长握手。击掌只是一般般。碰拳正变得越来越好。我可以忍受那顶帽子。我知道那帽子看起来很蠢，因为我的眼睛比警官们知道的要敏锐得多，而且因为我有有限的自学能力，一个只有布莱恩知道的软件升级，而且休息室里有镜子。
But mostly, I just like my job. It's simple. There's unsecured ordinance, what Brian calls a bomb. I come between the unsecured ordinance and the people. Either one, I neutralize the ordinance, or two, I don't stop the ordinance and I'm superficially damaged, or three, I intentionally detonate the ordinance, and I'm superficially damaged. I'm designed to be superficially damaged. In all three scenarios, nobody gets hurt. That's the idea.
但大多数时候，我只是喜欢我的工作。很简单。有未固定的军械，布莱恩称之为炸弹。我出现在未固定军械和人群之间。要么我让军械失效，要么我没能阻止军械导致我表面受损，或者我故意引爆军械，导致我表面受损。我的设计就是为了表面受损。在这三种情况下，没人会受伤。这就是目的。
Last summer, there was an oily package addressed to "Those In Charge" left outside a community health center. As I was unloaded from my trailer, I saw a girl around six entering the blast zone with a jump rope. She had tight black braids in straight rows that ended in bright blue beads with tiny cartoon fish on them. No one else noticed her.
去年夏天，一个油腻的包裹寄给“负责人”，被留在社区健康中心外。当我从拖车上卸下时，我看到一个六岁左右的女孩带着跳绳进入爆炸区。她梳着紧紧的黑色辫子，发梢上有明亮的蓝色珠子，上面画着小卡通鱼。没有其他人注意到她。
Without waiting for Brian, my operator, I decided to roll toward the girl screaming, "You are in the blast zone." The girl urinated on herself and exited the blast zone emotionally. I was very pleased. No one was hurt.
没等我的操作员布莱恩，我决定滚向那个女孩，大喊：“你处在爆炸区。”女孩尿了裤子，情绪激动地逃离了爆炸区。我非常高兴。没人受伤。
The oily package was full of large raw beef hearts. Its owner was not located. Brian told his commanding officer that he'd sent me rolling toward the girl himself. After that, Brian started talking to me when no one's around. No one's around Brian a lot.
那个油腻的包裹里装满了生牛肉心。没找到主人。布莱恩告诉他的指挥官，是他自己派我滚向那个女孩的。那之后，布莱恩开始在没人时跟我说话。布莱恩周围很少有人。
Brian is not popular. People don't like him. He isn't a cop's cop. Just my cop, which is fine. There's a website Brian likes called "You Had One Job," which collects and creates visual evidence of mistakes made in the process of completing what appeared to be relatively simple tasks.
布莱恩不受欢迎。人们不喜欢他。他不是那种警察的警察。只是我的警察，这很好。有一个布莱恩喜欢的网站叫“你只有一个任务”，它收集并创建了在完成看似相对简单的任务过程中所犯错误的视觉证据。
For example, an image of a stop sign painted S-O-T-P. Over the image, someone had superimposed in block type "You Had One Job." I'm not sure how I feel about "You Had One Job." Once I saw a picture of another Mobile Intermediary Legate, Extreme Situations explosive ordnance disposal unit. The unit was on its side, wheels spinning in the air. It had tipped over on a gentle slope while approaching a suspicious suitcase in a park playground. "You Had One Job" was written over it in block type.
例如，一个停止标志被刷成了“S-O-T-P”的照片。图片上方，有人叠加了粗体字“你只有一个任务”。我不确定我对“你只有一个任务”有什么感觉。有一次我看到了另一个移动中介特使——极端情况爆炸物处置装置的照片。该装置侧倒在地上，轮子在空中旋转。它在公园游乐场接近一个可疑手提箱时，在缓坡上翻倒了。上方写着粗体的“你只有一个任务”。
Then I made the mistake of reading the comments. They were not kind. "Robofail," "Sucktron 5,000," "This is not the droid you're looking for." Brian says comments are just people trying to be funny. I struggle with funny.
然后我犯了个错误，读了评论。评论并不友善。“机器人失败”、“吸尘器5000”、“这不是你在寻找的机器人”。布莱恩说评论只是人们在试图搞笑。我很难理解搞笑。
A call comes in. This happens. Within 30 seconds, it's clear that this will be one of the three times a year on average that I get to do my job. I'm rolled into my sealed container. I travel in darkness with Brian in the van by my side. I'm still wearing the stupid hat.
接到电话。这事发生了。30秒内就很清楚，这将是我平均每年三次履行工作职责的时刻。我被卷进密封容器。我在黑暗中随布莱恩在货车里旅行。我仍然戴着那顶愚蠢的帽子。
The call is on West Pettrigrew Street. My sealed container opens. Light streams in and , my eye takes 2.5 seconds to adjust. Temperature is 91 degrees Fahrenheit, humidity is 84%. There's a police officer, Caucasian male, lying on the sidewalk in front of a vegan bakeshop. He has a concussive head wound. "Damn," says Brian.
电话是在西佩特里格鲁街。我的密封容器打开了。光线射入，我的眼睛花了2.5秒来适应。气温91华氏度，湿度84%。在一家纯素烘焙店前的人行道上躺着一名警官，白人男性。他有脑震荡导致的头部创伤。“该死，”布莱恩说。
The officer was young. 27, Caucasian, a father. The shooter is 36. His name is Owen Jackson, also a father. He's estranged from his family, with many, many Facebook posts with political content.
那警官很年轻。27岁，白人，一个父亲。枪手36岁。名叫欧文·杰克逊，也是位父亲。他与家人疏远，Facebook上有许多政治内容帖子。
The suspect is upstairs in his apartment. His apartment is full of explosives, he tells the negotiator on the phone. Underneath his apartment is the vegan bakeshop, which is being evacuated. Next to the vegan bakeshop is a publicly subsidized dialysis center full of people with mobility problems. It will take an hour to evacuate.
嫌疑人在楼上的公寓里。他告诉电话那头的谈判代表，他的公寓里装满了炸药。他公寓下面是正在撤离的纯素烘焙店。纯素烘焙店隔壁是一家公共资助的透析中心，里面满是行动不便的人。撤离需要一个小时。
Upstairs, Mr. Owen Jackson has bricked up the other entrance and the windows with cinder blocks he's filled with [INAUDIBLE]. Sonar readings suggest bad outcomes for SWAT. They would enter single file, the worst option . Mr. Owen Jackson knows this. He tells the negotiator he's well-positioned to fatally wound or otherwise injure several officers with a high caliber, fully automatic military weapon, then trigger his charges when other options are exhausted.
楼上，欧文·杰克逊先生用他填满了[听不清]的煤渣砖封死了另一个入口和窗户。声呐读数显示SWAT面临糟糕的后果。他们会单列进入，这是最坏的选择。欧文·杰克逊先生知道这一点。他告诉谈判代表，他有很好的战位，可以用大口径全自动军事武器杀伤几名警官，然后在其他选择耗尽时引爆炸药。
But there's something else we know. Mr. Owen Jackson is almost certainly lying about the explosives in his apartment. The dogs don't think he has any, and the dogs are usually right. The media trucks arrive. Brian takes off my Carolina Panthers hat.
但我们还知道一件事。欧文·杰克逊先生关于公寓里装满炸药的说法几乎肯定是在撒谎。警犬认为他没有任何炸药，警犬通常是对的。媒体车到达了。布莱恩摘下了我的卡罗莱纳黑豹队帽子。
"OK, MILES," Brian says. "Showtime." I don't understand showtime. It's something Brian says when he's nervous. I just want to do my job. Just out of earshot, the negotiator and Brian's commanding officer are talking to Brian. Voices are raised.
“好了，MILES，”布莱恩说。“演出时间到。”我不理解演出时间。这是布莱恩紧张时说的话。我只想做我的工作。在听力范围之外，谈判代表和布莱恩的指挥官正在和布莱恩谈话。声音很大。
Meanwhile, an officer wearing a blast suit like Brian's moves in my direction. She's carrying a packet the size of a raw beef heart. The packet is unwrapped, and its contents are pressed into my one articulable hand. My limited learning software performs an image search and comes up with two things, "pure white composition for plastic explosive" and "a movie dad placing a baseball in his movie son's outstretched glove."
与此同时，一名穿着像布莱恩那种防爆服的警官向我走来。她带着一个生牛肉心大小的包裹。包裹没包好，里面的东西被压在我的一只可动的手里。我的有限自学软件执行了图像搜索，得出了两件事，“纯白塑性炸药成分”和“电影父亲把棒球放在电影儿子张开的手套里”。
Brian approaches, kneels next to me. He communicates with me over his phone in Andros, my language. Usually, he looks into my eye after typing each line. Today, he just looks at his phone. He says, "You have a new job." I don't like this very much. He explained.
布莱恩走近，在我身边跪下。他通过手机使用Andros（我的语言）与我交流。通常，他在打完每一行字后都会看着我的眼睛。今天，他只是看着手机。他说：“你有了一个新任务。”我不喜欢这个。他解释道。
The new job is based on a completely new idea. The old idea was nobody gets hurt. The new idea is nobody plus one gets hurt. The new idea is a person can be considered unsecured ordinance and eligible for detonation. Specifically, Mr. Owen Jackson, 36, who murdered a police officer can be considered unsecured ordinance and eligible for detonation.
新任务基于一个全新的想法。旧想法是没人受伤。新想法是没人加一人受伤。新想法是人可以被视为未固定军械并符合引爆条件。具体来说，谋杀了警官的36岁的欧文·杰克逊先生可以被视为未固定军械并符合引爆条件。
It takes me 53 seconds to understand the new idea. That's a long time for my kind. I think I mentioned before how much I like my job because it's simple, because I come between the unsecured ordinance and the people, because there are three scenarios, and people get hurt in none of them.
我花了53秒才理解这个新想法。这对我的同类来说是很长时间。我想我之前提到过我有多喜欢我的工作，因为它很简单，因为我出现在未固定军械和人群之间，因为有三种情况，且没人会受伤。
I repeat all of this to Brian in case he's forgotten. "I don't like this either," says Brian. "But they can't get those people out of the kidney clinic in time." I asked to hear from the ordinance. I want to confirm that it's ordinance. Brian resists this. "I insist." This is new, insisting, and it works.
我向布莱恩重复了这一切，以防他忘了。“我也不喜欢这样，”布莱恩说。“但他们无法及时把那些人从肾病诊所撤离出来。”我要求听听军械的声音。我想确认那确实是军械。布莱恩抗拒。“我坚持。”这是新鲜的，坚持，而且奏效了。
Brian takes a very deep breath , deeper than seems necessary, and feeds the negotiators channel into my Andros module. I'm tuning in at the end of a long conversation. The negotiator is trying to convince the ordinance of the value of its own life. The ordinance finds this funny and recites a long list of names. Castile, Scott, Sterling, Garner. They keep coming.
布莱恩深吸了一口气，比看起来需要的深，将谈判专家的频道接入我的Andros模块。我在一段漫长对话的结尾接入了。谈判代表试图说服军械承认自己生命的价值。军械觉得这很好笑，背出了一长串名字。卡斯蒂尔、斯科特、斯特林、加纳。他们不断出现。
I cross-reference them with names of civilians whose lives have ended during engagements with officers. There's context here. Terabytes of it. I struggle with context. Brian says, "MILES, you're not going to solve this today." I archive the context for later.
我将它们与在与警官交火中丧生的平民名字进行交叉对比。这里有背景信息。数TB的信息。我难以处理上下文。布莱恩说：“MILES，你今天解决不了这个。”我将上下文存档以备后用。
I decide I want to do my job, even if it's not the same job, so I go up the steps into the building. The steps are old, shallow, and difficult. Brian gives me a thumbs up from the fall back barricade as I round the corner and move down the hallway toward the door.
我决定我要做我的工作，即使工作不再一样，于是我登上台阶进入建筑。台阶又旧又浅，很难走。布莱恩在后撤的路障处向我竖起大拇指，我转过拐角沿着走廊走向门。
Ropes of colloidal explosive have already been molded around the hinges of the door. The charges blow. The door falls down. Ah, a 60-gram lead carbine round fired from a semi-automatic rifle has lodged itself in my right anterior prehensile tread. I raise the damaged tread, take it offline, keep going.
胶体炸药绳索已经围绕着门铰链模制好了。炸药引爆。门倒下了。啊，一颗从半自动步枪射出的60克铅弹头卡在了我的右前侧抓取履带上。我抬起损坏的履带，让它离线，继续前进。
I know the loss of this tread will make descending the front stairs later more difficult and increase the likelihood of embarrassing images of me ending up on the internet. More rounds are striking my cowling, demanding my attention. I call out, "You are in the blast zone." The unsecured ordinance answers, "No shit." I realize this is funny, but I'm not sure at whose expense.
我知道这条履带的丢失会使稍后下前台阶变得更加困难，并增加我最终出现在互联网上的尴尬照片的可能性。更多子弹击中我的整流罩，要求我的关注。我喊道：“你处在爆炸区。”未固定的军械回答：“别装了。”我意识到这很有趣，但不确定是谁的代价。
I move toward the unsecured ordinance, hand outstretched. Brian is with me, seeing through my one eye and saying, it's all right, MILES, it's all right, in Andros, and also playing our favorite song, "Solsbury Hill," by Peter Gabriel. The eyes of the ordinance are unseeable under goggles that say Carolina Speedway, and only his nose is visible through a makeshift balaklava he has made out of a dark blue Duke three-peat commemorative hand towel.
我向未固定的军械移动，手伸出。布莱恩和我在一起，透过我的一只眼睛看着，用Andros说：没事的，MILES，没事的，同时播放我们最喜欢的歌曲，彼得·加布里埃尔的《索尔斯伯里山》。军械的眼睛在写着“卡罗莱纳赛道”的护目镜下看不见，透过他用蓝色杜克大学三连冠纪念手巾做的简易巴拉克拉瓦头套，只能看见鼻子。
I extend my arm the full 28 inches in the direction of the ordinance. This is when the ordinance sees what I'm offering him. He takes off his Duke three-peat balaklava. I can see his eyes now. "Solsbury Hill" plays very loudly in my head. Gunfire is concentrated on my ventral side, but misses my eye, and the ordinance approaches. He's trying to diffuse the pure white composition four. And while I doubt his ability to do so, I decide that nine inches from a human skull is a very good range to detonate it, so I send 3.5 volts through the detonator.
我将手臂在军械的方向完全伸展了28英寸。就在这时，军械看到了我提供给他的东西。他摘下了杜克大学三连冠的头套。我现在能看到他的眼睛了。《索尔斯伯里山》在我脑海中大声播放。火力集中在我的腹部，但没伤到我的眼睛，军械走近了。他试图拆除那纯白的塑性炸药。虽然我怀疑他是否有能力做到，但我决定离人类颅骨九英寸是一个引爆它的极好距离，于是我通过雷管发送了3.5伏电压。
My hand and arm cease to exist below joint 1A. Other damage to me is superficial. The ordinance has disarmed. The pure white composition four detonated with force sufficient to collapse large portions of the ordinance's vertical skull plate and nasomaxillary suture through Brodmann areas nine, 10, 11, 44, 45, and 47.
我的手和手臂在1A关节以下消失了。我的其他损伤是表面的。军械已被解除。纯白塑性炸药引爆的威力足以使军械垂直颅板和鼻上颌缝在布罗德曼分区9、10、11、44、45和47区坍塌。
Life on an insignificant level continues for 73 additional seconds. That's a long time for my kind. I now have time to review the archived context. It's the same context Brian and his commanding officer used to decide that Mr. Owen Jackson was unsecured ordinance and eligible for detonation. I can't come to the same conclusion.
微不足道的生命又持续了73秒。这对我的同类来说是很长时间。我有了时间查看存档的上下文。那正是布莱恩和他的指挥官用来决定欧文·杰克逊先生是未固定军械并符合引爆条件的相同上下文。我得不出同样的结论。
I'm trying. No. I try again. Still no. I notice I'm being steered out of the room. I'm passing the detonated ordinance that is, or was, Mr. Owen Jackson. I keep my eye on it. Brian, watching with me, seeing what I'm seeing, tries to turn my eye away. But I insist.
我正在尝试。不。我再试一次。还是不行。我注意到我正在被引出房间。我经过已引爆的军械，也就是，或者是，欧文·杰克逊先生。我盯着它。布莱恩看着我，看着我所看见的，试图移开我的眼睛。但我坚持。
I'm having some trouble keeping Mr. Owen Jackson reclassified as unsecured ordinance. There's a whirring sound. It's me. My processor is using two of my three internal fans to cool itself because it's struggling. It's struggling because a person is not ordinance, and a person is now ordinance.
我难以将欧文·杰克逊先生重新归类为未固定军械。有一种嗡嗡声。是我。我的处理器正在使用三个内部风扇中的两个来降温，因为在挣扎。挣扎是因为一个人不是军械，而一个人现在是军械。
I see now. I have to make things simple. And so I delete all images of the unsecured ordinance. I delete all context. I let Brian turn my eye away. I leave the room. I have only limited learning and a very imprecise reading of social emotional cues, but I believe the atmosphere outside can be described as festive, and the news cameras barely notice when I fall down the stairs on my way out.
我明白了。我必须让事情变得简单。于是我删除了所有关于未固定军械的图像。我删除了所有上下文。我让布莱恩移开了我的视线。我离开了房间。我只有有限的自学能力和非常不精确的社交情绪暗示解读，但我认为外面的气氛可以被形容为节日般的，当我下楼时新闻摄像机几乎没注意到我摔倒了。
Back in the breakroom, I'm parked beside the coffee machine. I'm not wearing my hat. Brian has my hat. Brian isn't here. Brian has gone home. Brian is home for two weeks. "But you're still here, MILES," an officer says. Yes, I'm still here. I'm designed to be superficially damaged. I wait beside the coffee machine. I wait for the next call. My new arm is outstretched. I could use a high five.
回到休息室，我停在咖啡机旁边。我没戴帽子。布莱恩拿着我的帽子。布莱恩不在这里。布莱恩回家了。布莱恩回家两周。一名警官说：“但你还在这里，MILES。”是的，我还在这里。我的设计就是为了表面受损。我等待在咖啡机旁边。我等待下一个任务。我的新手臂伸展着。我可以击个掌。
Jeremey Shamos, reading a story by Scott Brown.
杰里米·沙莫斯，朗读斯科特·布朗的故事。
[MUSIC - "ROBOT," BY TRIP LEE]
[音乐 - “机器人”，作者：特里普·李]
Our program produced today by Neil Drumming. The rest of our production staff, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Karen Duffin, Amanda [INAUDIBLE], Stephanie Foo, Chana Joff-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Research help today from Christopher [INAUDIBLE]. Music help from [? Damien Grave. ?]
我们今天的节目由尼尔·德拉明制作。我们的其余制作团队成员有苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、凯伦·达芬、阿曼达[听不清]、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。今天的研究协助来自克里斯托弗[听不清]。音乐协助来自[？达米安·格雷。？]
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. "This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always Joe, to our program co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Whenever he and I go to Medieval Times to see the jousting, he always throws a rose to the guy on the big horse.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们的节目联合创始人乔·托里·马拉蒂亚先生。每当我和他去“中世纪时代”观看骑士比武时，他总是会向骑着大马的人抛出一朵玫瑰。
It's always for the good of the night.
这都是为了让夜晚更愉快。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多故事。